[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jonathan
is with us in Fort Meyers Florida hey
Jonathan what's up in your
world Hi how are you doing today Dave
better than I deserve what's up um so I
had a situation happen a couple years
ago uh during Co my mother passed away
um she was actually uh killed by her um
her new husband oh my gosh
man yeah they were both in their late
70s um and they um they left me with
quite a bit of
money wow so uh I had never uh I never
made more than about 85 Grand a year and
then was left with a couple million
dollars and I I hope I've been doing the
right steps um with what I've done with
it I just wanted to get mostly some
reassurance that I've been doing the
right things or what you would recommend
uh moving forward with this oh my gosh
how how have you navigated the last few
years with the loss of your
mom um you know uh the first year wasn't
too well um you know kind
of you know kind of went backwards
probably a little bit and then trying to
I got couple kids and I tried to get
myself together and be better for my
kids and I think I've been been doing
pretty well the last two years how old
are you Jonathan uh 36 okay and I assume
he the um the husband's been put in
jail uh no he killed himself afterwards
oh my
gosh yeah wow in our in our house that
we grew up in oh I'm so sorry geez man
well that just makes it I mean managing
two million dollars that you don't know
how to manage is freaky enough and then
you put this layer on it it just gets
super freaky
right yeah yeah it's a little more than
that um we were left about two two
million two and a half million from our
parents um and then he left us another
1.1 million oh
wow uh which we weren't expecting we
didn't know that we were written into
his will wow does that money feel weird
or are you happy to spend it
uh uh I I I've spent I haven't really I
wouldn't say I've spent it I've used
most of it to to live off of the last uh
couple years from the from the the new
husband MH um uh he left us two IRAs a
traditional IRA and a Roth IRA mhm so
I've been pulling let's get yeah let me
get past all the CR uh um and just
answer your question so how much money
do you have
today um today let me just flip over
here I've got total between properties
and everything yes I would say about um
three and a half million milon all right
and you're still working making
80 no I I haven't been working since the
day she died oh wow okay what did you do
for a
living I worked in restaurants mostly um
bartender somay and
server okay and and the reason I didn't
go back to work was a lot of that the
reason why I made good money was because
I was I was always forward about my my
life and talking to people about things
in my life and I just felt like I
couldn't do that
anymore well well you can't go into this
story part of the story anyway wow okay
are you are you married still or
single no I've never been married I'm
single you said you had kids okay yeah
two children uh one that I have full
custody of one that I play custody okay
an important part of your recovery
moving forward is you're GNA have to get
uh you're gonna have to get a job yeah
you're going to have to get a purpose a
thing to do a thing to go to a thing
that you are a part of that the world's
going to be better because you or a part
of it you got that yeah I feel that as
well okay yeah it's time it's time to go
back to work Jonathan doing something
I'm actually start I'm actually starting
a business this year a tour booat
business a whats tour booat a t a tour a
tiki boat tour boat oh okay all right
you're buying the boat and gonna yeah do
tours and right and do trips on the boat
when uh the boat's going to be delivered
in um April or May of this year and we
be operating by June okay what did you
spend on that
boat uh 220,000 total okay okay all
right now you're going to be leaning in
learning how to run a business learning
how to handle and operate the boat
you're going to be leaning in on all of
this I really want you to I want you to
go make a living for your sake because
at 36 doing nothing is not a plan okay
for to emotionally and spiritually
John's right about that now so let's
pretend that you're making a living you
don't need this money then right so now
we just need to invest this money
well yes okay Jonathan I buy two things
for Investments um the first thing I
tell people and I was with a bunch of
wealthy people this weekend do not put
money in something you don't understand
don't do it because I do it don't do it
because somebody else says to do it or
you read an article once that's a that's
a nightmare way to lose money put money
in something you understand now that may
mean you need to go to school a little
bit by sitting with an investment
advisor and letting them teach you uh
but I buy real estate that I pay cash
for because I like the real estate
business I've done that already okay and
I buy mutual funds and that's all I
buy okay I've got about um total about
1.8 million in real estate okay and it's
making money
right uh we I have one house that's
going to be worth about 1.2 million and
I'm planning on rent that M gonna be
when why is it not worth that
now that it's it's about to be finished
being built in I think in March or April
of this year it'll be done okay all
right so you're gonna have and then I
have a I have another rental house and
then I have the house I live it okay
that's fine great now manage those to
where they make a good return on the
amount of money you have tied up in them
and then sit down with a good uh someone
like a smart Vestor Pro you can find
them at Ramsey Solutions
and they'll help you sit down and start
to understand some mutual funds and
invest it but I mean if you make 10% on
$3 million average across that those
Investments then you'd have 300,000 a
year coming in uh if you don't touch it
in seven years that 3 million at 10%
would be worth about 4 millon would be
worth about 6 million in seven more
years it'd be worth about 12 and seven
more years would be worth 24 that's 21
years from today you're 36 that puts you
at
57 with $24
million I like that okay that's you
working providing your own living not
touching these Investments and letting
them just grow at an average growth rate
of 10% a year and that's invested in
mutual funds and real estate now it's a
little more complicated than that but
basically that's how the math will roll
out the trick here to the thing is put
money in stuff that's steady and is
predictable
not super conservative but not we're not
taking any big risks here we're not
trying to reinvent the crypto world or
some bull crap buyo for a quar million
dollars and then six months go and be
like well I'm going to do this and I'm
going to buy a snow cone stand and then
you're going to small business yourself
broke yeah stay stay on track with that
and so you're you're now in the tiki boo
business for the next decade buddy and
you're going to make a go of it you know
get John's right you don't get to change
create your free every doll budget today
the simplest way to BU budget for your
life